rocky is deep into the woods at the
bellagio she's there live getting the
story behind the new fall conservatory
display hey rocky
[Music]
hey jc yes we are here deeper into the
woods at the bellagio
and ed libby the designer of this place
he just said i'm smiling under this mask
because we're back here a new season
right it's a new season and i think that
there's something so incredibly special
about this particular incarnation of
fall we have so many beautiful symbolic
things throughout the thing look at
these beautiful snails behind you with
our hallmark bellagio fountains coming
out of their heads snails represent
patience and grace and if there's
anything more appropriate for the season
it's definitely to talk about the
patience and grace that brought us all
to where we are today um we continued
our fountain look across in the north
bed with this beautiful we actually were
able to procure this from the chelsea
flower show in the uk and this is
gorgeous copper sculpture with these
beautiful lilies that are all made out
of hand-blown glass so we're taking a
much deeper dive into like the art
and the um and the culture that is
bellagio
our family of bears has all been
beautifully groomed and fluffed up and
they have all new friends in the bed
with them hedgehogs and squirrels and
all kinds of fun things to
to find in there and our fox family is
have us a new addition
there's a little baby fox up in the tree
house that's a new addition to the fox
family that is so special what's going
on since the last time you guys were
here football for sure absolutely and
the last one was called into the woods
and this one's deeper into the woods i
feel like that's a little symbolic as
well i just felt like there was there
was so much more to the story than we
were able to tell in one exhibit the
dragonflies that represent
transformation inside this gorgeous tree
stump which is like our transition from
reality art a little sacred world in
here there's there's um shadow portraits
of all of the different other characters
that are in the bed so we really were
able to take the art of bellagio to a
different level in this exhibit which i
think is really very special ed thank
you again on behalf of all of las vegas
and the people that visit here to see
this beautiful display it's here until
november 13th so you can enjoy deeper
into the woods at the bellagio i will
send it back to you thank you rocky
we'll check back in with you during the
4 pm newscast